foreign
thank you
I barely kept up in the first talk so if
you get a head start
okay
foreign
[Music]
for this talk to be about is primarily
around so that polynomials perspective
of things okay and we'll see sort of I
guess methods for establishing spectral
dependence using very more like
algebraic or analytic tools inside your
polynomials so I'm going to do like a
little slide of hand here so I'm gonna
switch settings where the distribution
mu is supported on fixed size subsets of
a finite set this is really just for
convenience I can always homogenize
using say you know the
it's a coordinate of Simon paratrick and
so on okay so but you know I think for
convenience I'm just gonna assume it's
support on a fixed size subset so maybe
you think
for example
uniform distribution over Spanish
no we'll see some some more examples
okay
yeah I'll be a little bit uh
informal about this okay
okay so what is the rough theme behind
this this type of approach well the
theme is fine so I have a description
over Collections and stuff
so I can encode this distribution using
a big multivariate polynomial or I have
a variable variable zi for every single
element in the support or in the in the
ground set of my distribution and then I
have a monomial and then a coefficient
for every element in this for every set
in the support of the distribution
good catch
so here Z to the S is just I take the
product over all elements in s and take
the eye okay so this is a k homogeneous
multi-fine polynomial multi-fi meaning
there's no like x squared in there at
all
um and it's cable homogeneous all
monomials have the same degree
yeah let me just recall so just remind
you what the conditional influence
within what the
sexual Independence is the analog for
the the fixed size situation so if I
have two elements i j
it's given by a condition a difference
of marginals
the sample is set from my distribution
view the probability that J is in the
set
minus the probability that Json set
and notice here in things have changed
slightly where I no longer condition I
being not in the set but okay it's
potentially the same quantity and then
spectral Independence just says that um
large eigenvalue of this guy
and then we and then all of the mixing
results
okay so again the main thing is I want
to use analytic or algebraic properties
of this multivariable polynomial to do
something nice about the correlation
structure of my distribution okay
so this is actually this this approach
actually has a pretty long and Rich
history let me just give you like one
example of a result from many years ago
um of this flavor okay so let me so it's
an example
here
we'll see how this type of I think can
be useful for
sexual dependence so
there's a theorem
and
they're good
nine
that's the following so if
you knew of Z it's non-zero whenever
the imaginary part of z i is positive
role I
so you think of this as being for each
variable I draw the complex plane it's
going to be zero zero free in the upper
half plane okay
but then
for all I and J have the following
correlation inequality
probability that J
the conditional I is an s
the most
so in particular the distribution is
negatively correlated
so this is like one example of very
classical result that says if I have
some massive some really big zero free
region I can do something about the
correlations of the distribution okay
and this had there's many applications
this is a particularly nice and robust
notion of negative correlation as for
instance so these types of polynomials
are typically called real stable
polynomials and they were instrumental
in like the for instance the
breakthroughs of Marcus uh steel manager
vastava on kadison singer and
constructing ramanus and graphs and so
on
this is an example of type of theorem in
the space and I want to use
so now I want to use this for or related
or proof related theorems were
established in spectral effects okay so
that's the whole theme of this talk
okay so they're roughly
[Music]
they're essentially
okay so they're at least okay so there
are two properties that have so far been
used for in literature so so
properties although of course there may
be many more
undiscovered so two properties that have
been useful so I can think of G of mu
as a function
on say RN and I can ask that this thing
is log concave
and why you would ask for if you lock
and cave and not something else okay
you'll see in a moment so this is one
example of an analytic property of
distribution for the polynomial that
I'll be able to use to do something
about my distribution
and the second is just that similar to
this theorem
U has a large
zero free region
maybe not the entire half playing but
you know sufficiently larger now I'll be
more precise about what that means okay
so the final thought is I'm just gonna
like
uh
show the connection with lock on cavity
and then in a separate sort of part of
the talk talk about zero fruits
okay
so I guess the really the the main
connection here which is perhaps the
main takeaway of this talk is and why
you can even deduce correlation
inequalities from properties of the
polynomial it's the following connection
so it's following them
this is just okay so this says that I
can recover probabilistic quantities by
differentiating my polynomial
so for all I
look at the probability that I is in a
random set s this is equal to if I
differentiate the log of the polynomial
and I evaluate it all once
and the second thing is if I
differentiate again I get correlations
so for all time J
say all right not equal to J
probability I and J and S minus the
probability
I said s j is in this
this is equal to if I differentiate
and so
I've written probabilistic quantities in
terms of analytic quantities and so
that's that's really the the Crux of the
the connection okay
so
does anyone want to tell me a proof
yeah you just differentiate right I mean
the you differentiate use multilinearity
that it will pick out all the terms that
contain the variable that's it okay so
if I look at
first thing this is really a summation
over all sets that only the ones that
contain I Will Survive
they need to remove I from it but if I
validate all once I just get a sign okay
and then if I just do the calculation
over and over again
five seconds
um yeah I guess so technically you don't
so
okay at least for this one it doesn't
make a difference because G mu is
normalized okay sure
um but for this one you needed to get
this extra turn Okay so if you only
differentiating yourself you only get
this one
this is really equation
but you can look at either one of us
it's just more like traditional to get a
lot
okay
okay good okay so now I can say it
or this connection between say okay so
now what is log concavity so I'm going
to talk about lock concavity now
so it just says the following so it just
means that
I look at the Hessian
okay sorry just before I say this
so I look at the Hessian
of the log of the
polynomial this is negative
let's just say
simplicity
at all once but okay you can ask for it
for any points
so this is like just the classical
definition of Lock and cavity when I've
used when I have a function
all right so what's the connection so
we're going to use kind of this Lemma to
translate
what this thing is to suspectful
Independence okay
so in particular
mission
oh
so the following
or equivalent
cavity
same thing
as zero spectral inputs
the best you can talk for so think about
for instance the complete like I have
everything like it's uniform of all case
sets
quality or an equivalence
you can already kind of see it through
this thing uh through through this level
so maybe just to all right so I guess I
never believe this or should I
I'm sorry so I won't spell this out but
what I do want to do is sort of give you
for more a generic dictionary between
sort of three communities of people who
use different language
so
you know another dictionary
really I have
two there are three communities of
people
split it
more probabilistic
a more social
and there's the polynomials
okay so so the problem stack I had to
set up a distribution it's official I
have a weighted simplicial complex and
then polymers
okay so these are all really the same
thing
um look at the marginals
so
maybe I should say
instead instead of marshmallows again we
say
30 seconds
conditioning
conditioning on say find me S this is
really the same thing as taking a link
in the corresponding synthetical complex
and polynomials as we just saw it so
it's like you take the
shade
um we have
spectral Independence
let's say zero spectral Independence so
in some political complex languages it's
called like zero local
sexual expansion
and I hear in polynomials I have a lot
concavity
and I guess if you can also generalize
this so
ETA spectral
dependence
this is Ada over this one local
extension and I guess Nema has coined
the term fractional
um
but really just they're all the same
thing and we can all we can so sometimes
it's more convenient to like use one
perspective versus the other perspective
but
dictionary
okay
I mean okay I can say it's uh very
briefly so it's if you look at the
function but now if I raise it to a
power
variable to a power
equivalent to
okay
okay so I guess okay so maybe I'll first
focus on uh walking cabinets and zero
local spectacles mentioned or zero
spectral events
so if I have the equivalence then you
might ask again well then how how to
improve lock concavity to begin with
and really this just boils down to
this is where you can use some of this
like five dimensional expand or uh pools
so you can use the trickle down
maybe I'll state it this way
hold down
the polynomial version
so
if if I look at the Hessian
of my polynomial
so I can view it as like a weighted
graph
okay so this thing is
connected
as a graph
and
now let me just say let's look at the
derivatives
are all say log concave this is I guess
in some sense a special case where I'm
restricting to Lambda equals to one
or sorry Lambda equals zero
then
itself
is locked
so I'm going to hear this will imply
zero spectrum appendence and so on
let me give you
an example
so let's maybe talk about like uh
uh the example of spanning trees
we saw earlier how to do Spanish trees
for using a negative correlation but we
use local cavity you can get a
sort of sharper results
all right yeah so this is a matrix right
so maybe I should say I've evaluated
this thing at all once
this is the n by n Matrix I can think of
the entries as being the weights The
Edge weights of a graph and vertices and
I'm just saying ignore the values of
this weights as long as the
I have like an edge if it's not zero or
not if it's not zero and then it's the
graph
[Music]
are polynomial or is the positivity
a positive coefficient doesn't work
I guess I have to say
um one thing about this is that you can
actually generalize this
beyond the multilinear setting so as
long as it's positive coefficients but
it's homogeneous but it might have say x
to the five or Y to the 10 or something
like that this thing still holds true so
this kind of goes beyond this official
thing
so in some sense this is one reason why
you might want to formulate in terms of
polynomials because you can go beyond
simplicial
uh further questions
I just want to briefly talk about
spanning trees so really the the main
advantage of this theorem is now I can
kind of reduce the complexity of my
distribution so if I just start
differentiating and I get all the way
down to even just a quadratic polynomial
then all I have to do is verify those
quadratic polynomials are a lot concave
and then reduce my whole thing in the
whole polynomial
um so
we're spanning trees
yeah unluck was like spend too much time
on it I'm just going to briefly sketch
proof so you
foreign
so if you use just directly
Supply trickle down
devices
foreign
minus one I just differentiate n minus
three times to get a quadratic
polynomial and I just want to show that
all of them are locked up
this thing is really
the same thing it's just I have um
it's a genu of okay so this is really
but this is
polynomial
4G
uniform description of entries of G
after I have contracted
I'm left with like a two vertex graph
basically and and verifying lock on
cavity is
or three vertex but sorry and verifying
lockdown cavity is you can just like
like do it using like directly
okay
so that's all I really want to say about
this uh this technique
um
any questions so I'm gonna I'm gonna
switch gears to talking about uh zero
freeness instead of Lockhart Cavalia
are there any questions
oh right okay sorry yeah okay you're
right
sorry
okay
I guess I want to say like one last
thing regarding this
so I guess several people have asked me
before like okay so if everything is
really just trickle down in the end like
you know why would you ever like why do
you need a polynomials formulation I
guess like
one nice thing is that the polynomials
formulation sort of fits this kind of
result into like a larger class of
polynomials okay so for instance law
concavity manifests in many other
interesting settings
so a lot of concavity
elsewhere so
I can get volume polynomials
I mean I want to Define like what
exactly they are but these are very
classically studied polynomials and
Comics geometry the permanental point
polynomials
okay
let's say that um there are a lot of
applications in algebraic comments works
so for instance
so this is
um so really actually this
theorem was actually kind of was
independently discovered
by
foreign
ers
as I said they've used it for a lot of
applications in algebraic common tricks
but I won't get into it but I just want
to say that so this polynomial framing
of its even though you can prove
everything using triple down it has sort
of puts in like in perspective with
respect to many other lock-on cavity
phenomena that appear
okay so okay I want to switch gears to
zero hits
so I have a polynomial is for natural
ask about zeros so I'm going to prove
the following
yeah this is for really first
um
work of Ali mohammadi
panari
and long
and then we have some generalization
extension to more General zero fragrance
but basically it goes like this so
suppose
all right thank you let's see is
non-zero
whenever
now I'm just focus on like the all wines
Point okay so say z i are in just a
small ball
around one okay plus constant okay so
Delta here is like a small constant
but it's certainly much much smaller
than doing it for the entire uh half
plate like we saw earlier okay
then
we're going to do spectral dependence
I can even say that the Affinity Norm
that's okay what's that loss order
Delta squared okay so and I'll show you
an example of like how we can prove like
establish such as the open region later
on but for now I just want to focus on
uh infinity Norm my operating room is
also bounded but yeah
so let me just to remind everyone
and so bound to Max
imum
okay
now avoid writing that notation for the
rest of the time
I guess what's their definition
yeah yeah okay yeah writing another
error Infinity okay
Okay so
so I want to erase my
dictionary
okay okay
so the this is the key idea is the
following nice so so I'm I'm looking at
zero Fitness in the complex plane so I'm
gonna do some complex analysis
so really the key Lemma
it's got this nice
complex analytic statement
um
which sort of says characterizes like or
says something about the rigidity of
complex functions it's just the
following so if I have a univariate
function say F now mapping the unit disk
into the unit disk
does this notation okay so this this
subset of complex plane the complex
numbers with Norma most one
is
the f
olomorphic
say you know
smooth and the complex analog sense or
differentiable or whatever
um then for free just from the fact that
it's bounded and it's uh differentiable
then I can get a balance on the
derivative
that's it
for free okay so if I want to use this
to prove something like spectral
Independence I just really need to
construct a suitable Universe function
such that its derivative captures the
influence that's all I need to do right
so if I want to I just want to use this
thing as a black box so I really
so suffices
so I want to construct
so more formally I want to construct
Maps
let's call them the fee and C
and I'll specify like the image the
domain and range in a moment
such that
and they also so
let's say this way so that if I look at
F which is equal to the composition of
these Maps
say with capital openings within a sec
and we're okay so let me just label
these so they
um sorry do you know what they mean so F
typically I want it to capture
influences okay so I want to think of
say derivatives
maybe I want to first uh let's say for
fix fix and I so because I'm an upper
bounding the infinity Norm I just need
to show that for every arbitrary choice
of I the total influence is small
so I'm fixing I I want to show I want
this capital F to my differentiate it to
give me influences okay so I
differentiate with respect to J this
should be it should give me influence of
ion to J
what do I want out of Phi well I want to
use the zero freeness of my polynomial
so I just want to map
map the unit disk
into my zero free region
I guess just so that uh
okay
I can apply this line on and then I want
this one to map the image of f back into
the the unit disk so on the map
image
F back into
the unit disk okay
so if I can do this then I can just do
my chain Rule and say that okay
um so this would imply that if I again
just an imply The Dilemma one upper
bounds the derivative of C
and F
or once
the summation over J
of the influence
of the J times the derivative so I guess
C here should be like a vector valued
map v j derivative at zero
okay does this make sense
so all I'm saying is that if I want to
apply this Lemma I just need to
construct these simple Maps such that
out of it I get a univaric function
and
once I've applied it all what it says I
need to lower bound the derivatives of
these numbers
I don't think it's important to choose
so so F typically it's going to take
inputs so typically f is going to say
like log of my so
so
I say like oh
well the choice of fee oh okay sorry
so your question is
could you have absorbed it yeah okay
yeah I see I see what you're saying so
yes we can probably State a more General
version of short stick but then I still
need to construct a suitable function
here to satisfy the assumptions of that
like I can modify this with like maybe
different choices of the zero of the of
these regions but at the end of the day
I still need to construct one that Maps
the appropriate region into the
appropriate region
yeah sure but it's so yeah so I guess
you're also kind of anticipating what
I'm gonna how I'm gonna construct these
I guess for Simplicity I'm just going to
pick these together they'll eventually
be linear functions they just sort of
squash like the image especially so that
it gets stuck into a ball
but okay we'll see you in a second
I'm not sure if that
I see Sophie is is fixed website you
have to shoot it based on how you treat
that
uh right yeah definitely Sophie is
typically it's like it's just there's
nothing we can do about it because I
need to map the unit disk into the zero
free region because the zero region is
only where it's the only place I can
have control over my my polynomial
I mean the sports pick you can obviously
translate it and also dilate it so like
yeah yeah sure yeah
yeah
I guess for our purposes I'm just gonna
allow myself like a little bit of room
and put like Delta over two here okay so
because
okay I'll just say like what what my
choice for app is going to be
so I want differentiating F once I
differentiate F I'm going to get
influences out of it right so I'm going
to use the fact that you know uh
influences can be recovered by
differentiating log of the generating
problem
okay so recall
that
this kind of correlation is given by
differentiating twice
log if you knew
oops okay here will be my choice
of Z
just be I differentiate log of bmu only
with respect to the ith coordinates
because once I differentiate with the J
I'll give my my second derivative
and then for normalization purposes
divided by say the probability of I
guess so I get an influence and not just
a correlation or covariance
so
again oh sorry yes
okay let's see
okay so now so this is choice for f
okay so now you see I have log of
generating polynomial right that thing
is only well defined if the general
component is non-zero it's the only well
defined inside the zero three region
so my choice for fee is like I mean
there's not much you can do for it okay
I mean if you know more about yourself
region then sure you can do more but but
very Natural Choice and just for
Simplicity would just take this Choice
it's going to take Phi of J
to be
an offline function so
one plus
over two
times x
so the one is just to shift all ones to
zero the Delta is to uh
squash it down
and then there's also going to be a sign
a choice of a sign for s j so here the
SJ here you think of as being because I
want to Upper bound the absolute value
of these influences so I don't think of
this as being assigned
oh
this influence okay
and finally what is my choice for C
so I just need to prove that uh
maybe okay so I'll just say what my
choice for C is an improve it it will
actually work out the way we want to
record C is also just going to be a
linear function so it's just going to be
maybe some scaling by the probability of
I times
two times
so let's just like
we're all friends so this is constant
I'm just going to assume all these
marginals are constants
okay
so now I need to prove it okay
everything is that everything makes
sense that this composition actually
Maps the disk into the unit disk
that is holomorphic so first the fact
that this function is holomorphic is
clear now because I'm mapping
I'm mapping everything into the domain
in which GMU is non-zero so log of mu is
G mu is
also well defined analytic and
everything and so that's fine I just
need to the only trickiness is
establishing that it Maps the unit disk
into the unit disk
and
no
so
okay so here's what I want to claim so
if I
so I can kind of just get rid of this
but it turns out these two things kind
of cancel out so I'm just going to prove
the following claim which is sufficient
if I look at this function
and I
look at its image on
on its zero free region
this is contained
so
um
a ball that's not too large radius
once I can do that then I can then this
is the correct scaling to squash it down
back into the unit disk okay
it says that this function is not
blowing up the image too much
okay so first does everyone agree that
if I can prove this then we're
essentially good
this clearly the derivatives of all
these maps are nicely about
thank you all right so here's proof so
suppose
I have some Y which is equal to
this thing and I can expand out what you
know the derivative of log of Q mu looks
like what it actually is so
continue
let's see for some
CI in these balls and
because
so if I just rearrange so this is the
same thing
saying that okay so if I move everything
across
the MU of Z
minus 1 over y
derivative of G mu of Z
equals zero
so I have a polynomial and it's zero
somehow I want to use the fact that g mu
is non-zero inside this this uh in this
multitude to give a proof by
contradiction basically
so suppose
or contradiction
that's saying this y here has a large
then I'm going to use this to construct
a point in this 03 region at which G mu
is zero which is a contradiction right
okay
so there's a kind of a trick here that
happens
so I'm going to sort of add and subtract
falling quantity so this thing is equal
to
by G mu
minus the partial
so subtracting off all of the monomials
that contain the variable x i
now I'm putting it back and notice how
this part is really the same as this
part so this is x i minus 1 over y
partial Gene
so what have I done you think of this is
I've looked at all monomials and I
removed I only look at the ones that do
not have x i
it's like I removed X I from them and
here I'm putting x i back but I've
shifted X High by one over minus 1 over
y
so you think of this as being exactly
equal to G mu
for now I have x i minus 1 over Y and
then I've left all the other variables
untouched sorry I should not put X
guy
can everyone see this is this too low
okay so I basically written this
polynomial as just an evaluation of my
original polymer a slightly different
point
the other key point is that I've assumed
zi could be very close to the inside of
zero three region and since y has a very
large Norm one over Y is a very small
perturbation so z i minus one over Y is
still inside my zero for region
I'm planning here is equal to zero so
that's contradicting zero freeness for
my
polynomial and so on
all right cool okay so I just want to
wrap it up uh or spend the last 15
minutes to give you an example of an
application and I guess we'll see an old
friend which is matchings again
just done a different way
and I guess I should also say that you
know if you know more about yourself
region you know not that it's just
against a small ball but it's actually
say so the original
um
the original proof was looking at the
case when the deserve region is actually
very large it's a huge sector
and there you can for instance even
avoid having to have this dependence on
marginals but okay
you know basically upshot is if you know
more then you can construct better Maps
here
and let's do one example
okay so I guess of course aim again so
just to remind you
let's say new
it's uniform
matchings all matchings not just perfect
ones
maximum degree Delta graph
do this example of Charles will
illustrate like how you can establish
these kinds of zero-free regions okay
because that's not an easy task
so the proposition
and if I look at the matching polynomial
so this is
three
three let's just say
all of radius
one over the degree
so again if my maximum degree is a
constant then I have a constant size
ball around one
and if I once again use this to apply
spectral dependence this is another
proof of doing Matrix
that's right
so basically
how would you approve such a thing
and this is as far as I'm aware like
essentially all proofs have the
following flavor
with these like multivariable zero free
regions
typically I try to
start from something which is sort of
obviously zero free like a product of
linear forms and then slowly deform that
polynomial and then track how the zero
evolve
d
the recipe starts
products
your forms
basically something
obviously
and then
more
okay
so let me just say first what is the
starting polynomial that I'm going to
inherit zero three units from okay so
for matchings I can always think of a
matching
as follows
so
maybe I have a graph that looks like
this I don't know
I want to look at matchings on this
graph so I can think of it as follows
I'm gonna
build matchings I'm going to split each
Edge
so I dividing each Edge into a half Edge
and I'm just looking at matchings on
this new graph
satisfying the additional constraints
that
two edges that that came from the same
image they have the same steps
[Music]
same stats yeah so so I have this
matching here I'm looking at I wanted to
look at matchings here I can think of it
as looking at matchings here
but now I need so so let's say it's like
a Vertex U
h
B so this is an edge e i i divided this
Edge e into say I've identified which
vertex it came from
and then this Edge is now Edge comma V
these two like half edges so to speak
and I'm matching here is just I'm
matching here with the additional
constraint that
these two half edges they're either both
in the matching or they're both not in
the match
okay so with this view for matchings
and the point is that sort of now if I
just look at matchings on a star it's a
very easy object to look at right so the
polynomial I'm going to inherit is your
freedness from is the following so I
look at the product or vertices in the
graph
and look at one plus summation
over edges instant to that vertex of a
variable
okay so this is like kind of like a
product of linear forms I can analyze
this zero free regions very easily and
now the deformation is just going to I'm
going to slowly collapse these variables
so I'm going to start merging
variables xue xve back to a single
variable
okay I'm going to track the zero frame
the evolution of the zero food
okay so how I'm going to do that foreign
regions in statistical physics is called
the osano Rel contractions
it's a nice pool it was first used to
prove something called the Leon theorem
or give an alternative proof of the
youngster just a major result in
statistical physics so let's call our
son or real contractions
says the following so I'm merging only
two variables at a time so I can
actually just study a very simple
bivariate polynomial so the the claim
goes as follows so if
let's say the polynomial a plus b z one
plus c z two plus b z one Z two is
non-zero whenever
just have to check which exactly where
it goes
never say Z1 is not in subset K1
and then Z2 is not in some set K2
then I'll give some examples of these
zero features at the moment so basically
if I have sets for which this polynomial
is non-zero then
if I merge Z1 and Z2 into a single
variable then the polynomial a plus b of
Z is non-zero yeah
on
minus okay 1 times
this object is just
XY X
one
I can prove this number but basically
the point is that this allows me to
merge variables and I still get to track
how the zero three region evolves so let
me just give you a couple examples
so if
say K1 K2
they're both equal to the complement of
the unit disk
then K1
let's get two minus
for instance if it so happened that this
polynomial this this simple two variable
polynomial is zero free inside the
entire unit disk then by doing one step
of contraction it's still zero free in
that unit disk
one example
another example
is that if
a K1 K2
or
a big half plane
over here this is
zero maybe I have some Gap Epsilon
and this implies
okay one minus k
1 K2
this is equal to
so you can compute it out it turns out
to have like a parabolic region around
the zero three around the real axis
okay so with zero three
in a little bit more than a half plane
then it's going to be zero free in a
parabolic region
but the point is that okay so these are
just some examples like how you track
these sets
okay so I guess
at this point all I need to tell you I
mean if you take this as a given and you
sort of inductively contract through
this contraction step
um then all I need to show you is like
what is the zero region for this
and
I'll just stay here there's the Lemma
so
I just need to say zero region for each
of these linear forms right because it's
a product so for all vertices V
1 plus summation over e
x v e it's non-zero if
exactly a region of this form
so and everything a little bit more to
the
sorry it's this
basically a zero tradition this form
where the Epsilon here depends on the
degree
so
that's the last two
one over the maximum
it's here is something like
okay does anyone see the proof of this
exactly right so like if all the zero
all the real part of all the inputs are
larger than one over Delta there's no
way you can beat the one
so
okay so I think a lot of time
especially all I want to say maybe Alex
questions
okay if there are no questions let's
think quickly again
we'll meet again tomorrow for the last
day of the bootcamp